le chesnay renverser l'ogre montreuil au
deuxième tour de la coupe de france les
chesnaysiens qui évoluent dans le
championnat excellence se sont imposés
contre le 5e du championnat de dh dans
leur stade michaud ce match s'est résumé
à une histoire de penalty après avoir
réussi à ouvrir le score à la fin de la
première période les yvelinois ont
craqué en seconde période un commettant
une faute dans la surface
un partout à la fin du temps
réglementaire à la loterie des tirs au
but le chaînon porte 3 0 on a une équipe
qui était supérieur à nous mais sur le
terrain ça c'est pas vu parce qu'on a on
a vraiment eu quatorze joueurs
quinze joueurs même parce qu'il ya un
joueur qui avait qu'à pas pu jouer
quinze joueurs qui ont participé à cette
aventure on l'a préparé et voilà donc on
l'a on voulait bien finir c'était
l'objectif voilà c'est ce que c'est pas
nous qui avons été plus à la hauteur que
ils ont fait leur match ils nous ont mis
en danger etc
mais nous on a rivalisé on voulait
rivaliser voilà on a voulu rester au
contact le plus longtemps possible on
al'avantage ouverte d'ouvrir le score
après voilà eux ils ont ils ont fait
leur match nous on a fait un gros match
là mais on est capable ça veut dire
qu'on est capable de le faire maintenant
sur toute une saison c'est ce qu'il faut
retenir aussi ça a été un match
compliqué face une équipe de dh qui
n'était pas facile à jouer on a réussi à
marquer en premier c'est assez important
ensuite survenue sur un penalty assez
litigieux mais bon on a on a réussi à
tenir grâce aux consignes du coach faut
le féliciter et voilà on est on est on
est on est content de la qualification
mais va falloir continuer dans cette
coupe de france 4e du championnat
excellence cette année les chesnaysiens
vise à présent une épopée en coupe de
france lors de la saison 2016 2017
on va essayer forcément d'aller au 4e ou
5e tour pour aller un peu plus loin
après ça dépend du tirage
voilà mais les joueurs ont montré qu'ils
sont capables de faire plus que ce
qu'ils ont fait tout au long de la
saison voilà c'est ça que je sais que je
retiens et on va s'appuyer là dessus
pour préparer la saison prochaine ça va
être compliqué de répondre maintenant
parce qu'on est dans le forez mais
maintenant que la sorte une dh on se
rend compte qu'on qu'on a la possibilité
d'aller plus loin dans cette coupe de
france le 3e tour de la coupe de france
se jouera le premier week-end de
septembre on ne connaît pas encore
l'adversaire du chéné pour cette
rencontre